المدعيه سويسريه في عمر الاربعين اسمها
المستعار بريجيتا المدعى عليه طارق رمضان
حفيد حسن البنا مؤسسي جماعه الاخوان
المسلمين
التهمه الاغتصاب
وصل رمضان برفقه محاميه الى قاعه المحكمه
الجنائيه في جنيف للدفاع عن نفسه
تتهمه باغتصابها عام 2008 واخضاعها لافعال
جنسيه عنيفه في احد فنادق جنيفا
لقد كان يهاجمها منذ خمس سنوات ويصفها
بالكاذبه هناك شهود في هذه القضيه وهم
اطباء نفسيون استشارتهم بعد الحادثه بشكل
مباشر ودونوا ملاحظات في ذلك الوقت لاحظ
الاطباء الاجهاد واعراض ما بعد الصدمه ولا
يمكنهم الكذب بشان هذا النوع من الاعراض
رمضان استاذ الدراسات الاسلاميه السابق في
جامعه اوكسفورد يواجه تهما مشابهه في
فرنسا اتهمته اربع نساء بالاغتصاب بين
عامي 2009 2016 ما تسبب بحبسه عام 2017
لعده اشهر ليوضع بعدها تحت اشراف قضائي
وتقييد حريته وان ثبتت عليه قضيه بريجيت
السويسريه قد يواجه عقوبه بالحبس تصل الى
عشر سنوات
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات